i'm an engineer by background and came
to stanford for business school where i
met uh met sam became
friends uh started chatting about
different ideas what we might do after
business school and yeah we hatched the
idea of actually starting a solo
installation business at the time
focused on emerging markets
where energy is a big issue in terms of
access reliability and cost and so we
thought solar would be a great
great solution for that during our
summer of
business school we
put together this pilot project which
was a boarding school in nairobi kenya
that the whole thing souped to nuts
found the project designed it sourced
suppliers financed the system flew down
there and installed it the system was a
was a great success uh but
we also you know um realized how
cumbersome the whole process was of
going of going soul of designing solar
we were meeting nights and weekends uh
out of our dorm rooms in palo alto
trying to design the optimal solar
installation for a site halfway across
the world
and part of the challenges there were
first of all it was our first time doing
anything of the scale second of all we
weren't on site we had to hire people
locally to go and take a bunch of
measurements for us take a bunch of
photographs and we'll get all that
information back to our dorm rooms after
our classes were done and then try and
put together a solar installation that
would work it did take us essentially a
year
to do something that we thought should
be much easier much faster and it's
something that a lot of other people go
through
[Music]
if you look at any solar professional
they're essentially three key things
that they need to do in order to come up
with a solar installation for a property
first thing they need to do is be able
to figure out how many solar panels will
fit on the property the second thing
they need to do is forecast how much
energy those solar panels will produce
the third thing they need to do is how
much figure out how much money that will
save the customer
what aurora does is it streamlines the
entire process of answering those three
questions
when we were reviewing companies for
this year's ai 50 list aurora solar
jumped out because it was one of the
most interesting applications of ai
technology typically we see ai being
used for lots of things like
self-driving cars a whole range of
office and business services
cyber security things like that but what
aurora solar is doing is a little bit
unique where
they are using these advantages that you
can get from advanced ai
to custom design
solar power systems that on rooftops
that might ordinarily be a little too
difficult
to put solar on
the process of designing an optimal flow
insulation and doing that in an
efficient timely manner is actually
really difficult there's many different
steps you have to
run through many things you can optimize
right like where you place the panels
depending on the roof geometry depending
on the
shading that might be from a tree or so
forth different design configurations
and so
machine learning
and the optimization tools that we
developed allows us to automate the
entire process of designing a solo
installation it wasn't easy in the early
days back when we started it was just we
came out of the wake of the first
cleantech boom
a lot of people had lost a lot of money
you know investing in technologies that
didn't work out and so
solo was not a not a hot thing back then
the first five years of the company's
life we basically grew the company on
what is a very relatively small amount
in funding
for a company based out of silicon
valley but then within the last three
years we've had a tremendous amount of
traction
to date the company estimates it's
designed nearly 8 000 individual
projects
for about 7 000
residential and commercial customers
it's raised more than half a billion
dollars
including a 200 million funding round
announced in early 2022
and presently
it's valued at 4.4 billion dollars
according to a pitch book estimate wind
and solar together can be almost half of
our energy mix by 2050 and so it's an
incredible transformation that's
happening and so it was clear to us like
to get from where we were then and even
where we are today to that future there
needed to be a streamlined process and a
data-driven way of designing uh and
installing and deploying these solar
installations at scale i would say that
the one metric we've always tracked this
is from before we had any customers and
when we're just first building the
product and continues to be true till
today
was the number of projects that is
addresses that our software is being
used to design solar for right
and i still remember the big milestone
of the point where we got to a thousand
addresses a week right we couldn't it
was like this is amazing a thousand
addresses a week are going through our
software and being designed by it
more recently it's a hundred thousand a
week and we want to get to the point
where it's a hundred thousand per day so
those are the milestones that keep us
going and yes the funding valuation all
those things enable us to get there but
that's ultimately the real goal that
we're going for